so collecting comes with some oddities
and here's an example of it
as i put these two games side by side
they look pretty identical
but there's a huge difference
in that one of these costs about 25
times more than the other
with the difference being
with the actual content of the game
itself
in this case
this game was originally issued for
retail
as a car sim game
and this was the retail version
but later on in the lifetime sega
actually offered
through direct purchase of its website
an alternate version of this game that
had internet connectivity capabilities
called the netlink system
that at that time was a dial-in system
and you could connect and play through
very few quantities were actually sold
at time through the internet because it
was early age of the internet and people
didn't understand or know about this
alternate version
so definitely a collector
item
and one of those that are hard to spot
and find as a collector because of its
near identical components the main
difference being on the disk there are
identifiers that call it out as a
network condition and there is
additional manual components as well
[Music]